Нині Німеччина попри обіцянки ще не поставила Україні жодної одиниці важкого озброєння з власних запасів.
Більше того, німецька Welt am Sonntag із посиланням на отримані документи повідомила,
що за останні два місяці Німеччина надала Україні мінімальну підтримку.
Повільність канцлера в ухваленні рішень про постачання важкого озброєння Києву
спричинила жорстку критику з боку німецької опозиції і не тільки.
Олаф Шольц змушений виправдовуватися.
Через кілька днів після початку війни ми відправили ракети земля-повітря, протитанкові ракети -
тобто все те, що було гостро необхідно на той момент.
До цього можна додати понад 15 мільйонів одиниць боєприпасів для стрілецької зброї,
100 тисяч ручних гранат, понад п'ять тисяч протитанкових мін, великі обсяги вибухівки,
автомати, десятки вантажІвок з іншими важливими матеріалами, наприклад, для боротьби з безпілотниками,
засоби комунікації та засоби допомоги пораненим.
І спільно з Данією на прохання України ми відправили 54 модернізовані бронетранспортери.
Тепер канцлер анонсував новий план поставок Києву.
У найближчі тижні ми постачатимемо нові види озброєнь. Уряд вирішив поставити, наприклад, систему "IRIS-T" -
найсучаснішу систему протиповітряної оборони, яку має Німеччина.
Це дозволить українському уряду захистити ціле місто від російських ракет.
Крім того, ми поставлятимемо сучасну радарну систему, здатну виявляти ворожі гаубиці, міномети та артилерію.
Це рішення, яке ми ухвалили, забезпечить Україну найсучаснішою зброєю.
Ми робимо все, що в наших силах і з більшою точністю.
Проте коли саме Україна отримає ці озброєння, наразі невідомо.
Очікування поставок може тривати місяцями, адже систем ППО у Бундесверу зараз немає.
Компанія виробник "ІРІС-Т" нині виконує замовлення для Єгипту.
Розглядається варіант, що частину готового озброєння можуть перенаправити Києву,
але про це поки що не повідомлялося.
Крім оголошених Шольцем систем ППО та радарів, німці обіцяють поставити Україні танки "Леопард",
БМП "Мардер", зенітні самохідки "Гепард", а також гаубиці 2000.
Варто зазначити, що з перелічених озброєнь лише гаубиці є по-справжньому сучасною розробкою.
Лідерами з постачання озброєнь Україні є США та Великобританія.
Вашингтон вже навіть запустив програму ленд-лізу, а напередодні оголосив про надання Києву
нового пакета допомоги, який включатиме ракетні системи залпового вогню.
Можливості цього пакета включають високомобільні артилерійські ракетні системи або HIMARS,
а також керовані боєприпаси з дальністю стрільби до 70 кілометрів.
П'ять контр-артилерійських радарів, два радари повітряного спостереження, 1 тисяча додаткових Javelin,
50 командно-пускових установок, 6 тисяч одиниць протитанкової зброї,
15 тисяч артилерійських снарядів калібру 155 міліметрів, чотири гелікоптери Мі-17,
15 тактичних автомобілів, запасні частини та обладнання.
Не виключено, що Україна отримає ці системи вже скоро. Щоправда, поки йдеться лише про чотири комплекси.
Напередодні цього потенційного рішення президента Байдена міністерство оборони розмістило системи HIMARS у Європі,
щоб забезпечити їхню швидку доставку українцям.
Ми також розробили план для того, щоб ми могли негайно розпочати тренування українських військ,
забезпечуючи при цьому навчання для безпечної та ефективної експлуатації систем, а також їхнього обслуговування.
У свою чергу Великобританія надасть Україні американські ракетні системи M270 MLRS - аналогічні системам HIMARS.
США від початку війни в Україні вже виділили на військову допомогу Україні понад два з половиною мільярди доларів.
Постачаються бронемашини, гаубиці, протитанкові та протиповітряні комплекси, гелікоптери та бойові дрони.
Проте саме заява про HIMARS викликала бурхливу реакцію як у Європі, так і в Росії.
Ці системи мають радіус дії у 200-300 миль.
З безпілотниками і за наявності необхідних розвідданих це дозволяє вражати пускові установки,
пересувні установки або навіть завдавати ракетних ударів по базованій концентрації військ на далекій відстані.
Це повністю змінює хід боїв! Адже тоді ти не перебуваєш у зоні високого ризику та інтенсивного вогню.
Київ уже давно робив запити щодо цих систем, але США зволікали, зазначаючи, що це може спричинити нову ескалацію.
Але в підсумку Вашингтон зважився на відправку комплексів, запевнивши, що Київ не буде ними завдавати ударів по території Росії.
У Москві, втім, уже заявили, що не вірять подібним обіцянкам.
Це гарна новина для України та дуже погана для російських артилерійських розрахунків та їхніх командирів.
Ці системи озброєння, особливо HIMARS - реактивна артилерійська система високої мобільності,
були розроблені у 90-х роках і ще раніше, за часів холодної війни,
для того, щоб мати перевагу над російською артилерією.
І вони з цим добре справляються.
Щоправда, ми не побачимо їх на полі бою протягом найближчих кількох місяців,
але коли вони там з'являться, вони змінять ситуацію.
І тому також гарна новина - це заяви про постачання з Німеччини.
Тому що цим системам потрібна дієва протиповітряна оборона, і заява Німеччини допоможе в цьому.
Тож це чудові новини. Це врятує життя українців і може допомогти їм у веденні війни на оперативному рівні.
Системи HIMARS, які планується поставити Україні, здатні вражати цілі на відстані в кілька десятків кілометрів.
У США є установки з максимальною дальністю в 500 кілометрів.
Проте їх постачати Вашингтон поки не збирається.